[Música]
[Aplausos]
poquitos días antes de cumplir los 30
años una noche como cualquier otra me
fui a dormir sin imaginarme que a las 5
de la mañana me iba a estar despertando
con los ojos abiertos como si fuera un
búho y una sensación de miedo
indescriptible y además con tres
imágenes clavadas en mi cabeza
una que venía a rastras del inconsciente
y que me hacía recordar un hecho
traumático de la infancia otra que me
estaba haciendo recordar sobre un hecho
de la actualidad en ese momento que me
producía también descomunal temor y
otros sobre la incertidumbre del futuro
aunque en realidad estaba teniendo un
futuro bastante promisorio las tres
imágenes en concreto que se me habían
clavado en la mente me hacían no
solamente dar cuenta de lo frágil que en
definitiva estaba haciendo sino que me
producían mucha angustia y mucho miedo
tan así es que con el paso de los días
esa sensación de angustia se terminó
convirtiendo para mí como en una especie
de chicle pegado al pelo no podía
sacarme la de encima
así es que pasaron los días y tuve que
viajar en ese momento miami a dar una
conferencia
y después del viaje que no fue para nada
agradable por la ansiedad ansiedad que
tenía me acuerdo que seguía el hotel y
de pronto me encontré solo en una
habitación de lujo con el chófer
esperándome en el lobby la custodio
afuera de la habitación
y quebranto con una sensación de
angustia que ustedes no se pueden
imaginar
había estado durante los últimos años de
mi vida
escapando me del sentimiento angustias y
que cuando vino lo hizo lógicamente
potenciado por la cantidad de veces que
pasó sin que yo le prestará la
suficiente atención
se hicieron las doce de la noche y no me
quede otra que agarrar fuerte fuerte el
rosario que tiempo atrás me había
regalado unos mejores amigos y me puse a
rezar y a pedirle a dios con más
convicción que fortaleza y alguien me
voy a haber escuchado me imagino porque
por lo menos esa noche pude dormir sin
inconvenientes pero lo más increíble de
todo es que a la mañana apenas me
despierto
me pasó algo poco habitual me entraría
poco habitual no agarra de celular no
porque creo que la mayoría de nosotros
apenas nos despertamos estamos tanteando
con los ojos cerrados a ver dónde
dejamos el aparato pero en vez de tener
muchos mensajes del de los grupos de
amigos y demás tenía uno solo esperando
ser leído
y me llamó mucho la atención porque
quien me había escrito era una alcaldesa
de chile- amiga con quien hacía un
tiempo que no hablaba
se llama carolina plaza y es una mujer
absolutamente espiritual y sensible ese
mensaje todavía lo tengo grabado se los
voy a leer porque me impactó y eso que
esto pasó ya hace dos años
carolina me escribía y me decía leandro
cómo estás anoche soñé contigo me venía
a saber y me decías que no estabas bien
recuerda que aquí tienes una amiga que
espera que y es a tu país ya muchos por
un mundo mejor no dudes de eso
yo no soy esotérico ni nada por el
estilo pero después de la peor noche que
había pasado en mi vida recibir una cosa
así por lo menos
me erizó la piel
pase de pronto de ser un come mundo en
ese momento a sentir que el comido era
jon es ir había trabajado mucho por
conseguir lo que había conseguido a tan
poca edad y cuando llegue a todo lo que
me imaginé que era lo que estaba
buscando me di cuenta que en definitiva
no me había salvado encontrarme conmigo
mismo es decir ustedes imagínense que yo
tenía menos de menos de 30 años
viajaba mucho trabaja de lo que me
gustaba y económicamente no me estaba
yendo mal tampoco era bill gates pero
está bien salía aunque no parezca con
con chicas bastante lindas
estaba en lo que he visto desde afuera
podría ser una situación excepcional
pero aún así había algo que a mí no me
estaba sintiendo haciéndome sentir feliz
ese último año había estado para mí
marcado por una cantidad enorme de
desafíos y de cargas que yo suponía que
podía llevar a cuestas y que en realidad
al final no lo estaba pudiendo lograr
hacer
pérdidas familiares rupturas amorosas
conquistas nuevas rupturas desafíos
laborales inmensos
y el miedo a perder lo conseguido en
algún punto me hacía sentir como si
fuera un malabarista amateur que con
polémica estrés e intentaba mantener los
afectos el amor el dinero el trabajo en
altura tratando de que ninguno perder
altura y terminará hecho trizas en el
piso había en definitiva ha pasado el
suficiente tiempo sin darme cuenta de
que en realidad toda la fiesta que yo
estaba haciendo no terminaban siendo
divertidas porque no nos estaba
compartiendo
no me había dado cuenta que en realidad
el enamoramiento está genial si lo
logras transformar en amor si las
caricias verbales te tocan el alma y no
el ego si los premios te hacen más
humilde y si con las conquistas cuidas
al otro
volví a buenos aires y tuve que hacer lo
que hice carrel rehacer me desde el
sufrimiento porque en definitiva el
hombre es al mismo tiempo el mármol y el
escultor así que no hay otra forma de
hacerlo me acuerdo que volví y me senté
en la computadora y tenía tanto por
decir tantos sentimientos acumulados que
escribí una carta abierta a los jóvenes
que en realidad no estaba haciendo una
carta abierta a los jóvenes sino estaba
haciendo una carta dirigida hacia mí
mismo me estaba hablando a mí mismo nada
más que se publica a sacarte pues se
terminó idealizando
pero en definitiva era una querella
contra mí mismo estaba tratando de
explicar o de explicarme que era lo que
en realidad yo pensaba de la vida
después de todo lo vivido a los 30 años
entre otras cosas yo no suelo creer en
aquellos que dan consejos de vida
más bien lejos de eso yo creo en el
poder de los ejemplos no de los consejos
de hecho a veces siento que coexistimos
como en un tiempo histórico en donde los
que más saben estudian y los que no
enseñan y no me refiero precisamente
entre universidades pero por eso saben
cambien estoy en que con esta carta
abierta yo no no trataba de darle
consejos a nadie sino que estaba
mostrando el camino simplemente que yo
había transitado esa carta después se
terminó convirtiendo en el prólogo de mi
último libro lo que me dejan los 30 y
entre otras cosas
en esa carta compartía algunas
reflexiones como la siguiente justo
cuando a mí me estaba pasando esta
situación me llamaron de colombia para
una entrevista de radio y los oyentes
eran casi todos casi todos jóvenes y
estaban preocupados por lo mismo el
éxito es decir la persona que estaba
haciendo la periodista que está que
estaba haciendo la entrevista abrió el
público poder para que pudiera hacer
preguntas y era una pregunta
absolutamente repetitiva que era para mí
el éxito eso tan personal tan
intransferible tan indefinible
cansado un poco de que me hicieran esta
pregunta justo a mi encima como si
tuviera la razón absoluta le dije chicos
la empresa más importante por la que
ustedes pueden trabajar es su familia
los afectos los lazos
una casa más grande un auto más
importante un reloj más caro el puesto
de gerente que tienen ahora o el que
están buscando si es verdad son
importantes pero en definitiva no los
van a hacer más felices a largo plazo
sino en todo caso más distraídos
recuerdan siempre pero siempre que al
final del camino lo que va a importar es
el amor entre los suyos del resto el
resto sólo eso para mantenerse ocupado
cuándo
una de mis abuelas de 99 años estaba
internada en el hospital a punto de
fallecer al lado de su cama no estaban
ni los trajes que gino bogani le hacía
medida ni los embajadores con quienes
había compartido escenas de lujo estaba
su familia pero más precisamente mi mamá
al lado de la cama como estaca velando
por su integridad
cuando fuimos al cementerio a despedir
justamente a esta abuela que les digo a
mí hay un hecho que me llamó que me
quedó súper marcado la gente cuando en
cuando entraba al panteón a dónde a
dónde se hizo la ceremonia si o si había
emplazado en el acceso a este panteón o
una placa con un poema al que casi nadie
le prestaba atención pero casi nadie ya
mí me quedó grabado el poema decía tú
qué preso del placer cierras del alma
los ojos
contempla en estos despojos lo que eras
lo que has de cerrar ven aquí a apreciar
del hombre la duración que en esta
triste mansión de desengaño y consejo
cada tumba ese espejo
y cada epitafio elección
desde mi perspectiva existen dos tipos
de admisiones esto que nosotros
perseguimos tanto
una te lleva a trabajar para crearte más
importante que los demás y la otra para
ser más sutil
si trabajas solo para demostrar lo mucho
que puedes acumular al final de cuentas
te vas a quedar viviendo en la
especulación pero si por el contrario lo
que haces es trabajar por el legado lo
que vas a dejar es una vida mejor para
otros y eso indiscutiblemente te
convierte en parte de la historia
tengo un amigo en los últimos tiempos
bueno ustedes estarán al tanto mucho a
ustedes seguramente también repiten
repiten esto que les voy a decir está
muy de moda la frase soltará y confiar
soltar no sé a dónde y confiar no sé en
quién pero
si bien es cierto que es válido soltar a
veces para no vivir presos de la
obstinación igual de cierto es que las
cosas que más valen por lo general son
las que más cuestan ganar la lotería es
para pocos porque si por cada tropezón
que atravesar vas a soltar esperando a
que algo mejor suceda y lo más probable
es que te pase la vida soltando el
trabajo perfecto no existe la familia
perfecta no existe se consigue con
sacrificio este amigo que les decía alec
oxenford creador de remate puntocom
en la antigüedad o lx ahora o let's go
se pasó muchísimo tiempo de su vida
tratando de convencer a la misma persona
para que aportara con capital a uno de
sus proyectos 14 veces 14 le dijeron que
no a la vez 15 consigue el dinero que
necesitaba sin ir más lejos o
siguiéndome más lejos pero en la misma
dirección cuando yo tenía 19 años viaje
a córdoba a presentar un libro en ese
avión conocí a una azafata que para mí
era la réplica angelina jolie pero en
versión latinoamericana era una belleza
el único problema los dos problemas en
realidad que tenía yo en ese momento era
que todo es lo primero que yo era muy
tímido y después que casi todos los
hombres que se bajaban del avión al
hacerlo o le pedían el teléfono o le
decían algún piropo yo dije claramente
la estrategia mía no puede ser esta por
qué
así no voy a ganar nunca
así que podría haber elegido soltar y
esperar a que el universo me diera lo
que yo pretendía o terminar haciendo lo
que hice volvió a buenos aires fue una
tienda de regalos
compro una caja gigante con trigo
gigante y o gigante le puse adentro un
peluche un teléfono celular y una carta
si tenía 19 años ya no hago más eso y me
fui hasta la oficina de personal de la
cndh en aeroparque cuando llegué era
toda una oficina de mujeres la jefa de
personas desarrollan todas bastante no
sé si porque me veían medio que estaba
colorado por la vergüenza o qué pero no
me quiso dar los datos de la azafata por
cuestiones de seguridad pero sí me
aseguró que le iba a llevar la caja y
que se le iba a entregar se le va a
hacer llegar me fui bastante contento
supongo ya la semana recibí un mail de
ella agradeciéndome
estuve cuatro años de novios y creo que
hasta el momento fue una de las
relaciones más sanas que tuve en mi vida
ni álex en lo profesional ni yo en lo
personal salvando las distancias
soltamos nada por el contrario nos
abrazamos fuerte a nuestros sueños y
luchamos con ingenio por ellos
alec también me dijo y me dio el mejor
consejo que pude haber recibido a los 23
años estamos tomando un café yo
preocupado por la situación del país y
como yo iba a crecer bueno tenía dudas
existenciales como cualquier esa
me cortan sé que mi hijo pide viajar
viajar me hizo entender entre otras
cosas nuestra visión doméstica de la
realidad porque caminar
por el mundo te hace conoce hace a vos
más solidario y menos solitario
conocer tantos sueños caminando por el
mundo te hace realmente una persona
mucho más profunda ahora el tema es que
muchos jóvenes creen que yéndose a vivir
a otros sitios van a conseguir la
felicidad
y el problema de esto es que justamente
los inconvenientes que tengas con vos
los vas a llevar en la mochila vayas
donde vayas sencillamente porque podemos
distraernos de nosotros mismos pero no
escapamos en algún momento te encontrás
o te chocas contra vos así que el mejor
viaje que siempre uno puede hacer tenga
nada que tenga es hacia nuestro interior
probablemente como les decía a través de
varias relaciones algunas más
conflictivas que otras así que les digo
para el caso de aquellos que estén en
eso porque vemos bastantes que son de mi
edad probablemente alguno esté por
elegir el compañero de su vida y si es
así y en contra de casi todos los
consejeros sentimentales le diría que la
experiencia me hace creer que el amor
indicado no es el que te hace sentir
primavera en invierno sino paz en todas
las estaciones y si por el contrario ya
están por ser padres o madres
les pido encarecidamente cuiden sus
palabras al criar un hijo un niño no
tiene la capacidad para comprender las
restricciones del contexto y por eso a
veces se culpa y asimila como exactos y
asertivo los prejuzgamientos que otros
van a ser sobre sí
la pureza a un niño no le permite
deducir las limitaciones de los otros
dicen que me suelen decir a mí o
psicólogos que ante la adversidad el
inconsciente suele recurrir a recuerdos
de la infancia como herramientas para
ayudar a sobreponernos son algo así como
salvavidas que nos ponemos cuando caemos
en el mar de una realidad turbulenta
como si fueran pilares en donde se apoya
y sostiene nuestra personalidad y no
imagino realmente alguien que durante su
desarrollo fue sometido a latigazos
verbales sacando del cajón algodones en
vez de alambres de púas
en lo personal y esto lo remarca mucho
en la carta y en el libro me vengo
equivocando lo suficiente desde muy
chico que hago cosas como para darme
cuenta que si bien es atractivo enseñar
es mucho más
es mucho más significativo perdón a
aprender que enseñar porque hablar antes
que oír te convierte en una especie de
charlatán engreído y caer en el error te
has humilde porque posiblemente tengas
que pedir perdón y trabajar por subsanar
lo hecho el error entonces te has
humilde humano y por eso te acerca a los
otros y te conecta con la capacidad de
perdonar y ser perdonado el error te
enseña siempre a ser empático y eso
genera indefectiblemente un mundo más
tolerante
si a los 18 años como me pasaba a mí
pensar como alguien de 50 lo más
probable es que estés actuando como un
retrógrado pero si a los 50 seguir
pensando como alguien de 18 lo más
posible que estés actuando como un
idiota los jóvenes son idealistas y de
sociedad listas son la columna vertebral
del mundo los que lo hacen andar los que
le dan sentido
de ahí la necesidad de que los adultos
con su experiencia puedan trabajar junto
a los jóvenes porque si es de otra forma
y lo hacen por separado el joven se
convierte en soberbio y el anciano
seguramente en depresivo
es paradójico ahora que está tan de moda
el tema de la autoayuda el otro día le
decía un amigo que es muy fanático de
esto el libro autoayuda que posiblemente
terminas de leer porque no soportas la
angustia que te causa la crítica ajena
es el mismo que acaba de comprar la
persona a la que recién ofendiste
necesitamos colgar menos mandalas en la
pared aprender menos aún medios
armonizan test y poner más en práctica
la frase de san agustín
amaral errado y odiar el error cuando
los japoneses reparan un objeto dañado
tiene una técnica de llama kim soo kim
que unen las partes donde se daña el
objeto con oro y hacen esto porque creen
que cuando algo ese año tiene una
historia y por eso se vuelve mucho más
bello no solamente se llama quien sushi
también se llama traducido la belleza de
las cicatrices
gruesos contemporáneos tensiones que
existen prójimos con dificultades sino
gente tóxica y partiendo de este
concepto
lo importante en realidad va a pasar a
ser tu habilidad para sacarte los encima
en vez de ayudar los peligrosos
conceptos porque si todos creyeran lo
mismo el resultado es más intolerancia
una humanidad que camina rumbo a la
soledad cuando me pasó lo que me pasó me
di cuenta que aceptar la tristeza es
dentro de parámetros razonables no
lógicamente una virtud que posibilita el
desarrollo
nos ayuda a entender que gracias a su
existencia podemos valorar la felicidad
nos confronta con ella haciéndola ver
como un valor un ideal al que perseguir
la tristeza te convierte en insatisfecho
y por consiguiente te empuja a moverte
para ser mejor
los hasta ahora pocos malos malos
momentos que yo tuve en la vida puede
atravesar los gracias a la fe la
pregunta que siempre me salvó ante la
desesperanza es sobre el sentido de la
existencia
acerté esta pregunta puede ayudarte a
entender que los problemas a veces no
son el final del camino sino parte del
recorrido
cuando me preguntan por qué no sea te
respondo simplemente porque no me
conviene porque creer que eso es una
canica arrojada en el mundo por capricho
del universo además de ser una idea un
poco desmesurada debe transformar a la
vida creo yo en un naufragio dramático
el año pasado recorrí más de 20 ciudades
mexicanas presentando un ensayo llamado
el derecho a no ser pobres me acuerdo
que en esa oportunidad
en una de las presentaciones en una
alcaldía había cuando termine la
presentación una fila enorme de gente
y esperando para poder auto graphics que
yo les autografiara su ejemplar
en ese evento estaba el alcalde su mujer
la reina de la belleza no faltaban hay
empresarios locales todos impecablemente
vestidos y entre medio de esa fila se
asoma un hombre con la ropa rota sucia
el descalzo como tres meses sin bañarse
barba larga
se acercó a mí y la custodia que estaba
con una como tomado por sorpresa no
sabían qué hacer este hombre me tocó el
hombro
y saco una servilleta de entre sus
bolsillos que había logrado conseguir
pidiéndole a la gente que estaba allí en
el cóctel y me dijo podrías dejarme una
dedicatoria aquí te agradezco muchísimo
por lo que haces
me patio el tablero de tal manera que
ustedes no se imaginan desde ese momento
todas mis certezas pasaron a convertirse
en incertidumbres
si se me hubiera aparecido un genio en
aquel momento antes de este episodio
esa noche la cena no la hice la alcaldía
terminé cenando con este hombre y si
hubiera sido antes de este período y se
moviera aparece un genio y muy ha
preguntado que deseo cumplir me
seguramente le hubiera dicho tener la
capacidad de convencer a los
inconvenientes
increíble después de esa noche lo único
que pretendo para los demás es que si
para mí también lógicamente es que su
mirada pueda transmitir lo mismo que lo
de este hombre si te falta todo menos
paz
en realidad no te falta nada
tiempo estén en donde estén tengan la
edad que tengan de ese tiempo no corran
tanto y hagan con el de la vida de su
vida
un cuento que contar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]